by now you've probably heard about the
Panama papers it's the biggest leak in
history 11.5 million documents revealing
how a bunch of politicians and rich
people are avoiding taxes by stashing
cash offshore but you might also know
that offshore tax havens are totally
legal so we got to ask do these leaks
actually matter after all the Panama
papers aren't the first to drop a
bombshell about the rich and powerful
abusing their riches and their power
consider three of the biggest data leaks
over the past few years the Iraq and
Afghan war Diaries the Snowden files and
the Swiss leaks war crimes mass
surveillance and tax evasion were
revealed in those other leaks but not a
single person was held legally
accountable except the whistleblowers of
course so why would the Panama papers be
any different well it's too early to say
the extent of the impact they'll have
but the papers do reveal the sketchy
offshore activity of 12 current and
former heads of state and more than 60
relatives or associates of politicians
and within 48 hours of the leaks
thousands of Iceland ders protested in
the streets of Reykjavik causing the
Prime Minister who hid millions offshore
to resign elsewhere Austria is now
investigating two banks for possible
money laundering and Australia is
investigating 800 people named in the
leaks now representatives of some big
names implicated in the leaks like
Pakistani Prime Minister Nawaz Sharif
and ukrainian President Petro poroshenko
have maintained there's been no
wrongdoing on their part and that might
be the case legally but that doesn't
mean people won't have a lot to be angry
about because these offshore tax havens
they house a third of the world's wealth
and half of all global trade passes
through them that's no small sum there's
at least twenty trillion dollars hidden
offshore that's more than the entire GDP
of the United States
all those avoided taxes means less
funding for infrastructure health care
education government programs that we
all depend on and while no American
individual or company has yet to be
named in the leaks it's probably coming
American companies that offshore tax
havens go together like American
companies and offshore tax havens over
70% of the fortune
500 hold two point one trillion dollars
offshore leading the pack Apple with
over 181 billion dollars in tax havens
so the Panama papers do matter they've
shown once again how the world's 1% try
to protect their wealth and any cost but
what are we going to do about it